good morning John I guess I'm old now
and you know how I got to be okay with
it here's what I did I lied about my age
but I turned 38 I realized that there
was practically no difference between
that age and 40 both in terms of how I
was going to feel physically and also
how I was going to be perceived so I
just started to say I was 40 and now
it's been completely normalized for me
so there was no sense of like a negative
aging moment in this wonderful birthday
which was really great I may have lived
my entire life perfectly to have the
best possible 40th birthday and
isolation the part of that is having a
really wonderful family and a really
wonderful child and so I wasn't actually
isolated I was with them but I also have
a lot of practice at and experience with
finding community on the Internet and I
want to thank you John and also
everybody in this community for being a
part of that for me it's really helpful
in these times but there's a bunch of
other reasons why I had a great birthday
and I want to go over over them the
first one is that I had time and a
chance and the inspiration to write a
song and so I'm gonna play a song on
this channel which I haven't done in a
long time there is a piece of our
Anatomy it's important and it's great
it's the final destination of that
chocolate bar you ate inside it is
inside and outside it is out and I think
it's pretty clear exactly what I'm
talking about but there's one thing that
I didn't learn
and so I cannot help but ask I wonder
what's inside your football I wonder
what's inside your butt although maybe
it is astronauts and maybe it is aliens
all inside your butthole it's inside
your butthole
I always want to know what's inside you
thought hole I always want to know oh
maybe it is dinosaurs and maybe this
monster trucks all inside your butt Oh
[Music]
if you saw the thing on Twitter you know
that I didn't I did not write that song
was written by an eight-year-old child
who went viral on Twitter with really
good song about buttholes I had it a
little bit at the beginning of the end
to round it up was that necessary for
this to be a work of genius no thang
number two pure serendipity my son slept
in he walked into the room and he said
happy birthday daddy
when he usually says waffles or
something similar
ly demanding number three my parents in
LA watched the nerdfighter created
all-star Smash Mouth mash-up with
vlogbrothers clips but they don't know
what smash mouths all-star is so that
was their first exposure to Smash Mouth
his all-star number four finding the
original is amazing but making a Smash
Mouth cinema jig is next-level number
five was at the grocery store getting
groceries and they carded to me and I
was like I'm turning 40 today and you're
you think I might be 21 then I realized
that I looked like this so it's a little
less impressive I haven't aged a lot in
the forehead I think number six
none pizza with left Hank has now almost
outsold none pizza with left John and
it's on sale for another I think two
days so maybe that'll happen but in any
case waking up to find out that that
existed was cool day number seven I
literally finished my last edits to my
book and sent them in and we're
officially 60 days two months from
publication right Katherine did
something so nice that it would really
made my year I want to explain what she
did in order to have other people do it
for other people but I also just want to
cherish it in my own heart and it would
take too long anyway I don't have time I
had to sing a whole butthole so it also
Arne made me this ladybug sitting on a
leaf rock sculpture and he made me a
card and when I asked him what's on it
he said a spiral which I thought John
you would appreciate thank you John for
doing things for me thank you everyone
for doing things for each other it's
it's the it's the real stuff right it's
the real stuff
sometimes I attempt to end eloquently
not this time it's the real stuff John I
miss you I'll see you on Tuesday